this morning we're going to continue our
special focus on Mental Health kids in
crisis with a look at solutions to help
struggling teenagers this evening
cbsnews.com and our CBS own stations
across the country will exclusively
stream the documentary connecting the
dots exploring the global youth Mental
Health crisis Meg Oliver spoke with a
group of New Jersey high schoolers
enrolled in a special class learning
simple strategies to ease stress and
improve their learning and their
well-being
uh
three days a week grinnelly's Cruise
Maddie Torres and Alex Kumar meet with
their High School social worker Kristen
Madden we could start with some
breathing exercises to just kind of get
us calm in 2020 the Parsippany Hills
School District in New Jersey started
the strive program it offers at-risk
youth academic support for the classroom
and teaches coping skills for their
emotions I got depressed and it wasn't
really good I was kind of in my room a
lot and it wasn't really fun how bad did
it get for you it got bad it's
definitely been better since I've gotten
in this program I think the last few
weeks have been hard for me for sure
yeah
why have they been hard
just like school
and Ms Madden definitely helped me this
morning
on this day Maddie was struggling with
some online teasing she's not alone
numerous Studies have shown an
association between increasing social
media use and depression researchers
found that teens compared themselves to
curated images posted online and feel
inadequate and insecure raise your hand
if you've been depressed
raise your hand if you've struggled with
anxiety
raise your hand if you feel like you're
in a better place today
I'm having more of a smile on my face
now I'm being more positive Kristin
Madden wants parents to know that their
children are facing bigger challenges
than when they were adolescents it's
real for these kids usually they're not
trying to be difficult they really are
struggling
have you ever seen it this bad never
breathe in for four seconds in addition
to academic support Madden teaches her
students coping strategies from breath
work hold it for seven seconds to
grounding one of the activities that you
can do anywhere if you're feeling
anxious is a grounding activity it's
called 54321 so five things that I can
see is the board
the flag your glasses
the note paper and then
four things you can touch my water
bottle the pens
the table and my skin three things you
can hear voices of the elevator
and the clock ticking two things you can
smell
Alex's food wow
my lip gloss and one thing that you can
taste the pizza I
it's a tool she says anyone can use
during an anxious moment the important
part is that you're able to interrupt
what is going through your mind it just
kind of brings you back to focus on
things I mean if you're in the middle of
a state of anxiety and you have to look
around and pick five things to see and
really focus on them it interrupts the
cycle of anxiety The Prompt that I
picked today was what is one thing
you're proud of achieving Madden also
stresses the benefits of journaling and
focusing on positive aspects of your
life I had to go great on my math test
and I'm like really terrible at math so
I'm proud of that we know that gratitude
helps reduce anxiety and depression and
being in a state up here and now and
being grateful for the things that you
do have rather than focusing on the
things you don't and I think with
teenagers that's especially huge because
they compare themselves so often to
other students what do you want other
kids at home to know about why it's so
important to talk about your mental
health it's not good to keep it bundle
together because you will literally lose
your mind because that it's happened to
me before and it's not a good feeling
it's okay to ask for help you don't need
to suffer with silence it's all right
not everybody's going to accept but
you will find the right people
grinnelly's told me the most important
thing she wants parents to know is to
just be there for their kids and experts
say parents need to take care of their
own mental health to best help their
children that slogan is catching on the
it's okay not to be okay and the more we
talk about it the more helpful it is
that grounding exercise what does that
do just to make you stay in the present
it basically breaks up the anxiety so if
you're having an anxious moment and you
start going down 54321 you start looking
around and what can I see what can I
hear what Can I taste and then it brings
you back that's something we can all do
I think so too and I wanted there to be
a really like concrete takeaway for
parents and students because we know
they're in trouble but these programs
are working but you know the other thing
Meg that I was think that I took away
from this is the amount of when I was a
kid and I was bullied I could go home
and the torment ended when I walked
through the door of my house because
there was no social media and also I
wasn't inundated with images of who I
was supposed to be when I was at home
and now kids today I really were worry
for them because they are 24 7 under the
microscope feeling the pressure gun
violence and there's that bully could be
in your hands yes or not even not even
somebody you know it's an image that you
see on social media that tells you you
should be like this you were bullied in
in school high school junior school high
school all through for a very long day I
moved around a lot as a kid so always
being the new kid was always very
difficult I wasn't sporty I was very
nerdy yeah and into you know Dungeons
and Dragons the things that like you
know that nerdy if you could go back and
talk to little Vlad what would you say
well I would try to do that grounding
exercise because that really is
something that centers you in the moment
and also to it's what you said Gail it's
okay to not be okay but also that Vlad
would not know this flat and that is the
most beautiful part of life it's gonna
get better and it does get better it
does the other thing I liked in the
piece gratitude helps reduce anxiety and
depression and this isn't very important
for people to think about they can use
their smartphones to journal use your
voice memos all that kind of stuff
there's a smart way to do that thank you
Meg thank you well done great Meg thank
you thank Oliver a reminder the
documentary is called connecting the
dots it's available on Demand right now
at cbsnews.com it's very very well done
and very good if you or your child is in
emotional distress distress rather call
or text a suicide and crisis Lifeline at